welcome to exploring computing
today's video is digital images part
two let's get colorful let's go back to
the last lecture where we had our laptop
and we had a magnifying glass and what
we're going to do is we're going to
somehow crank up the magnifying ability
of that magnifying glass and take an
even close look at this computer screen
what will happen when we take an even
closer look at the computer screen is we
will discover that each the individual
pixels
consists of not a single square which is
either on or off it actually consists of
a number of what are referred to as sub
pixels
now the exact geometric configuration of
these subpixels will vary from one
computer to another
mostly on the basis of what the
particular computing technology
used is for most lcd screens the sub
pixels will actually be bars
and there will be a red bar a green bar
and a blue bar
if we were to take a close look at an
old school cathode ray tube or crt we
would actually see that there are
actually three different circles but
again there would be
a red circle a green circle and a blue
circle
and you will hear computer scientists
often talking about rgb
where r stands for red g stands for
green and b
stands for blue so most color on the
computer is done using rgb
we'll take a look in a couple minutes
about how printers work and they
actually have a different system
called cmyk we'll take a look at that a
little bit later
for now though let's again take a look
at our red green and blue
the idea here is that by mixing the
amount of red green and blue we can
actually generate different colors
let's take a look at a little computer
program i wrote a couple years ago
this particular program is actually
written in python which is the
programming language that cs105 students
will be learning a little bit later on
this quarter although
we won't quite get to the point where
we'll be making slight graphical user
interfaces like this
so this particular program shows what
happens when we mix
red green and blue colors together
right now i've got red green and blue
all set to zero
so there's no light on at all and so
what i'm going to do here is i'm going
to go ahead and crank up the red here
and you can see i'm slowly getting more
and more red and i can max it out at 255
which is the maximum amount of red that
the computer can put out
and let's go ahead and turn that down
you can see i can do the same thing with
the green
and then finally blue and then of course
the interesting thing is when we go
ahead and try and mix them so here i've
got a little bit of
blue maybe about 30 percent
i can go ahead and mix in some green you
can see i get different shades of green
here depending on how much green
intensity i have
i can start mixing in some red and by
mixing these different colors
and changing the intensity of the red
the green and the blue
i'm actually able to create lots of
different colors and so this is actually
how the computer itself is going to be
generating colors
it's got that red green and blue bar or
as we saw in the crt it's got those red
green and blue circles
and by increasing the intensity of those
individual bars
it's actually mixing colors we don't see
the individual colors because
they're really really small and so what
our eyes see is
just the lights that are being combined
together but in fact if we were to take
a microscope here to the computer screen
we would actually see the individual
bars
lighting up at different intensities
let's take a look at some actual color
examples so naturally red
consists of red turned all the way up
with no green and no blue although we
can create different shades of red by
either increasing or decreasing the
intensity of the red from the maximum
amount to some lesser amount or by
slightly mixing in some green or some
blue
blue is of course similar with no red
no green and the max amount of blue and
then we can start mixing things so
if we turn our red sub pixel to
half the maximum intensity turn the
green sub pixel off
turn the blue sub pixel to half the
maximum intensity we'll get purple
if we turn the red all the way up and
the blue all the way up again leaving
the green off we're going to actually
end up with fuchsia
similarly if we turn the green to half
the blue to half
turn off the red we get aqua whereas if
we crank up the green and the blue all
the way again leaving the red still off
we would actually get teal
we can get more exotic colors as well so
here's some samples these are from the
html5 specification which we'll be
talking about later this quarter
you can see here see green consists of
green but not green up at maximum
intensity only 139 out of 255 and then
mixing in some red
and some blue but mostly those are
pretty far down remember this is a scale
that goes from zero to 255.
burly wood consists of a lot of red
a fair amount of green and still a fair
amount of blue but less than the amount
of green and red
and a tomato you know that that's mostly
red
red turned up pretty much the maximum
here but also mixing in some green and
some
blue so these are examples of the
different types of colors we can create
using this system and in fact
we can create 16.7 million colors using
this particular system
how did i get to 16.7 million colors
well let's take a closer look at how
these colors are actually represented
inside the computer
here's how the color cardinal red is
represented inside the computer
we can see that there are 24 bits or 24
switches used to represent
this particular color these 24 bits are
broken up into
sets of eight which you'll recall refer
to as bytes so we have one byte set
aside for red one byte set aside for
green and one byte set aside for blue
in this diagram you can see that i put
the decimal equivalent on here so that
the combination of red switches on the
far left the combination of red bits on
the far left
is equivalent of a decimal 140. the
combination of
eight bits in the middle corresponds to
the amount of green
which is a decimal 21 and the
combination
on the right again is the same as the
switches for the green and that again
represents the decimal number 21. so the
computer knows it should
set the red to somewhere a bit over half
maximum intensity and then it should add
in just a little bit of green and just a
little bit of blue
now because the amount of red is
represented by
eight bits and you'll recall from our
previous lecture that
in eight bits we can represent two to
the eighth combinations which is 256.
we'll want one of those combinations to
represent zero representing that no
light
comes out of that particular subpixel so
instead of going from 1 to 256 we'll go
from 0 to 255.
so we have red 0 to 255 green 0 to 255
and blue 0 to 255 which is what you saw
in our last example when i was
sliding around the sliders on a little
python program
now because i have two to the eighth
possible combinations of red
two to the eighth possible combination
of the green and two to the eighth
possible combinations of blue
i actually have a total of two to the 24
possible combinations
and it turns out that if you work out
all the possible combinations with all
24 bits
i get a bit over 16.7 million so we
generally say that in 24-bit color we
can represent 16.7 million colors
now this 24-bit color system is
one of the most common color systems
used on computers today but there's a
fancier variant of this
which uses an extra byte this is the
32-bit color system
in the 32-bit color system we actually
have an additional
byte and that additional byte is
actually set aside to represent
something called
alpha alpha represents the opacity or
transparency
of a particular object and we use this
if we're sliding one object on top of
another object we want to show
a little bit of the object underneath it
and you can commonly see this technique
used when we're moving
windows around an operating system
let's take a closer look at how our
alpha works
what i've got here is i've got a pair of
images here i have
an image underneath which is uh parked
near
the louvre and then i've got an image of
the tower of london
in the top left-hand corner i have the
park overlaid with the tower of london
and i have alpha set to higher percent
with alpha set to 100 percent
the london bridge image is going to be
completely opaque we will not be able to
see through it
but as we reduce the opacity we'll be
able to see
increasing amounts of the paris park
underneath it
here we've got alpha set to 192 out of
255 which is 75 percent
you can see that the the park is
starting to bleed through
um if we reduce it even further here
alpha's set to
50 or 128 out of 255
and you can see that we're starting to
see a lot more of
the park underneath and you can also see
that um
our parts of the tower of london which
are not on
uh on the paris park are starting to
look a little bit faded and then finally
in our last image here
um i've got alpha set to 25 which is 64
out of 255
and you can see that um we can almost
completely see
the park and the image of tower of
london is almost completely faded
if we crank down alpha even further we
were to set alpha for example to zero
we would not be able to see the tower of
london image at all
let's take our newfound knowledge and
apply it to something
practical say for example suppose we're
interested in buying a new television
here's a webpage for a new television
from samsung on the best buy website so
if we take a quick look at this webpage
the first thing that stands out to me is
you can buy a brand new
hd television for 329.99
why don't i have one of these seriously
um
these prices are really low anyway so
let's take a look at
uh the specifications for this
television we'll focus on the title line
here
we can see this is a samsung that's the
manufacturer
that it's 55 inch this is the distance
from
one corner of the display screen to the
opposite corner we can see that it's an
led
this is talking about the display
technology used this is as opposed to
say for example a plasma television or
an old-school cathode ray tube
television
the new 6900 series that's an internal
samsung designation so that's not
something that's going to be
particularly useful
unless you're planning to buy
specifically samsung television
so this is 2160p the 2160 refers to the
number of pixels
from top to bottom the p actually stands
for progressive
all modern displays are progressive in
order to understand what progressive is
we need to take a look at an older
technology which uses an
interlaced signal so for example
an old-school vcr tape was interlaced
and the idea here on an interlaced
signal was that um instead of updating
every single line on the television we
would update every other line on the
television so let's say
our signal was coming in and we were
able to get information
30 times a second what would happen on
interlaced
signal is the first 30th of a second
every odd line on the television would
be updated and then the next 30th of a
second
every even line would be updated and
then every odd line would be updated and
progressive television every
line is updated all at once so this is
on the one hand this is a really good
thing this
is actually the big difference between
vcr tapes which were interlaced
and dvds which were progressive so you
know if you've ever played
those two technologies this was a huge
improvement but
it's not particularly interesting to us
as someone that's buying a new
television because
all new televisions are progressive
smart is referring to the fact that this
can be
connected directly to the internet and
that there uh
that it has the built-in ability to do
things like display say for example
netflix or hulu or disney plus
4k is referring to the number of pixels
wide
in this case there are 3840 pixels
across from left to right and uhd tv
refers to ultra high definition
television
which again refers to the fact that this
has a lot of pixels wide and a lot of
pixels tall so this is
ultra high definition television is as
opposed to
high definition television which is 1920
by 1080 pixels and so
we can actually fit four hdtv displays
onto this television because this has
four times as many
pixels if we go ahead and multiply out
the number of pixels from
left to right and top to bottom this is
four times as many as would be found on
hd television
i think this last part here the hdr is
actually the most interesting so hdr
refers to high dynamic range
there have been a number of important
improvements in display technology
since say for example the dvds were
defined
one of the differences is that we have
much higher pixels per inch so
you know we've just seen that this has
many many
pixels tall and many pixels across
in fact we have four times as many
pixels as on
hd television another difference though
is that
modern televisions have much better
contrast so
the difference between the darkest darks
and the lightest lights is much much
higher than
they used to be and we also have higher
overall brightness
now in order to take advantage of this
contrast between the darkest darks and
the lightest lights
we need a new system for defining colors
we've talked previously about how
modern computer technology uses 24-bit
color so
eight bits for red eight bits for green
eight bits for blue
um 24 bits overall leading to a total of
16.7 million colors what hdr does is it
actually
increases number of bits
for each individual pixel it increases
the number of bits for each of the color
channels
there are a number of different
competing standards there's one standard
that uses 10 bits for color channels and
another one that uses 12 bits for color
channels i'm going to talk about the 10
bit for color channel
example because this seems much more
prevalent so one of these
10 bit per color channel standards is
this
hdr 10. with hdr 10 we're going to set
aside
10 bits for red 10 bits for green and 10
bits for blue and what this
is going to do is instead of allowing us
to set intensities between 0 and 255 for
each of these three color channels
we're going to be able to store
intensities between
0 to 1023 intensity so
we're able to have many many more
gradations and in fact um if we were to
go ahead and do the math
remember before we had 2 to the 24th
giving us 16.7 million colors now we
have 2 to the 30th which gives us over a
billion colors
so this is just going to give us much
more variation of colors and much more
able to represent
an actual image so this is actually a
pretty neat technology that
should greatly improve your image on
your television set
previously i alluded that printers use a
different color technology than displays
do so let's take a quick look at this
the main idea here is that the printed
page and paintings
create color a different way than our
laptop display does
let's take a quick look so our laptop or
our computer or
television create color using what's
referred to as additive color
the colors generated by these different
display technologies
create color and shine them into our
eyes in contrast if we think about how a
painting or
printed page works what we want is we
want a bright white light
and the white light will shine on our
printed page or our painting and what
happens is
the different inks in that printed page
or
the paints used by that painting are
going to absorb parts of that white
light
so the white light contains all the
different colors
in the color spectrum and some of those
colors get absorbed by the printed page
or the painting and what remains gets
sent into our eyes or gets reflected
into our eyes
and so this is referred to as
subtractive color so this is a
fundamentally different way of
generating color than what we've seen
with
the displays and so there's actually a
different set of primary colors used for
printing technology as we previously
seen
the computer screens use rgb red green
and blue as our primary colors
and it turns out that the printers use
cmyk
so they use cyan magenta yellow
and black and so if you were to buy a
printer cartridge you're not going to
see that
printer cartridges have red green and
blue they actually have cyan magenta
yellow and black you don't actually need
black it is technically possible to
create blacks mixing a whole bunch of
cyan
magenta and yellow inks but it turns out
that that uses a lot of ink and
sometimes gives you kind of muddy
results another thing to note about rgb
versus cmyk
is it turns out that there are colors
that you can generate in one color
scheme that you can't generate in
another so
you really should be making a decision
when you're going to create an image
whether
that image is meant to be used on a
computer screen or on a printed page
and so what you can do is you can choose
certain colors because you know that
they're going to work well in one of the
color schemes and not in the other color
scheme
you'll also discover we're going to talk
later in the quarter about how to design
a website and color schemes for websites
and one of the ways that you might
choose colors for a website is you're
going to use a color wheel
it turns out that there's a different
color wheel used by artists
and the artist color wheel naturally
using the the
primary colors for painting using
subtractive color
whereas the web color wheel is used
based on the additive color of rgb
okay we've been looking at how computer
displays work and how they generate
color
what we're going to look at next is how
programs represent
images and manipulate images and then
we're going to take a look at different
formats that are available to store
image information
and we're going to talk about the
different choices you'll have when using
images on the worldwide web in the
proper formats to be using
you